what I'm going to be talking about  tonight is the optimistic view which I  take of the future of economic future of  this country in the world  I don't think innovation is exhausted by  any means I'm not sure how we would know  what the future of innovation is but I  don't think it's exhausted but but I I  think my main point is that the world is  is developing the whole world is  becoming richer we are in a period of  the fastest world growth and income per  head in history and when China and India  and sub-saharan Africa and Latin America  come online we're going to have in the  next fifty or hundred years a world  cultural economic you can sports  intellectual explosions such as you have  never seen